congratulations on the success of this
show coming into season 1 with any
reboot or a revival or continuation
especially now it seems to be so common
to have the response you've had how does
that feel it's unbelievable I mean it
really is I mean this franchise has
caught lightning in the bottle twice you
know with the original Karate Kid film
being what it's become and what it's
turned into over decades of time and
then to have the big fat warm embrace
around the world for the Cobra Kai show
is just you know it's there rolling
that's what we're hearing it's a you
know having your cake and eating it too
and I credit the three creators of the
show Jon Josh and Hayden who have a
specific vision and you know someone
needed to drive this ship and and they
are the biggest fans of the Karate Kid
I've ever met they know way more about
that film that I do all of them and and
so they want to make the show that the
fans want to see and they were able to
do that and thread the needle for within
nostalgia and yet relevance for
present-day storytelling and that's
where it did marries together so nice so
I feel highly intelligent for saying yes
I got a bit lucky again also pairing you
up again with Billy and a lot of big
did that feel like something that kind
of clicked again overnight or was it
something at the keys back into after
all this time it's interesting I you
know Billy and I that first scene we did
together it's the end of the second
episode a real poignant scene that kicks
the series into rivalry gear and that
was the first scene we shot together and
it it took a half a second for it to
feel like yesterday outside of the
wrinkles and the receding hairlines and
and yet it felt as fresh as a minute ago
and that's kind of how the series works
too I don't know what the reasoning for
that is I think you know were the right
actors and the right roles at the right
time with the support of the the great
writing in the setup and the way their
guys have set up the two sides and
flipped the script a little bit and
figured out ways to make these
characters that were initially certainly
in the rivalry sense black and white
good over evil now that's a gray area
with moral ambiguity and there's there
are other levels in colors as often
happens as we get older and enter Mitch
not everybody is as miyagi would say not
everything is a seam right I was gonna
say I'm lady said flip the script
because this show definitely does that
and so if you were to take the original
and have it be that Johnny had studied
under mr. Miyagi
and you would studied either like how
would that have worked differently and
that's kind of a hypothetical but it's
it's interesting to think about I mean
the one thing you know Daniel Larusso
has always been even though he has a
feisty knee jerk kind of little
temperament eastcoast temper which gets
him into trouble at the base of that
character is a big a big wholesome heart
and that's where the connection with
Miyagi was in the fatherless child
meeting that sort of human Yoda to help
guide him help guide him through
adolescence Johnny Lawrence comes from a
different place I think might have I
think you know it's hard to say if they
would have swapped and under different
tutelage to come out the same but what's
interesting about the Cobra Kai series
in the way it's designed is that these
are T and it's so entertaining as well
that the us is the audience sees that
these two guys if they could just get
past their crap could probably get along
and it's us you know it's so close to
seeing a sequence in Episode nine of the
first season that they sort of come
together and you believe like whoa these
are compatible personalities that have
that have similarities in their
upbringing and in their in their
journeys but then one went left one went
right and that's what happens as soon as
you think that they might get along
something wrenches thrown into the plan
it is really the karate soap opera it
really is well another hype okay
hypothetically
maybe I guess is that Daniel was kind of
a villain of the series all along have
you seen that have you thought about
that and that's is a you say this again
the the fan theory that Daniel really is
the villain of Karate Kid right right
well that was someone did that it was
kind of cool to do like about five or
six years ago the point of view that
Larusso came in and was the villain and
all this stuff and Lawrence was just
innocently going on with his life
I don't think it holds a ton of water
but I love the fact that people are
talking about it and yeah you know there
were times that both of these characters
you know would not always make the the
most consciously supportive decisions
for the other person but then it therein
lies the story in the conflict I think
that you know in this series when we
open in season one you know they were so
successful it's and Lawrence's we learn
to understand Johnny Lawrence a little
bit more so we have sympathy for him but
then as the season goes on we find the
russo needs to regain the balance in his
life and find those the legacy of miyagi
to realign his focus and brings that
forth and in season two now he's really
looking to carry on the legacy of mr.
Miyagi and those great teachings of
Okinawan karate and the self-defense of
it all and and that it is not aggressive
and negative and and so so the spirit of
Pat Morita is mr. Miyagi lives on in the
series and was a big big reason why I
move forward to do it because that was
of utmost importance to me that that
wasn't lost in just the rivalry between
you know Johnny Lawrence and Daniel
Russo and so the guys have done a great
job of weaving all that throughout
speaking of
continuing his legacy I saw at my
research that Pat's daughter was here
recently yes that must have been
emotional it was just two days ago just
two days ago she unbeknownst to me lives
not far from where we shot a scene on a
beach which was a highly Miyagi
influenced scene in an episode 4 of
season 2 and she emailed me that she was
in the area and I had to come down it
was very moving it was awesome his
presence is all around this show and
it's great and that's probably got the
most Instagram and Twitter hits I've
ever had
by putting up a picture of me and her I
asked her permission to do that because
I know the fans would love it and it's
it's really nice really nice I set the
stage for me season 2 where do we pick
up and all those a bit of a cliffhanger
gala season 1 so how do we see things of
all of this season well it I mean I
can't give too much away because that's
part of the beauty of what worked the
first time people had no expectations it
picks up right where we left off
literally it's almost like you know you
just you know took a quick commercial
break and it's back it picks up right
where it left off and you know season 1
interestingly was always a set up for
season 2 which is you know it's sort of
the battle for the San Fernando Valley
what's cool line of thinking what school
of thinking is gonna work in miyagi doe
versus Cobra Kai and it's a struggle for
Larusso to now try to create a pathway
where where people and students will
come to me ah geez side of Miyagi
decider of thinking when it's far sexier
to you know smashing fist through bricks
and fly through the air you know so so
it creates some challenges it also
creates some challenges for luery so and
the fact that now his business and his
family is he's trying to balance all
these things that look it's sort of
midlife crisis he at times
and and maintaining focus and on top of
that john crease is back in the world of
Johnny Lawrence not to mention when
Larusso learns that he is back that more
is more fuel to the fire and then on top
of all that stuff the great storylines
of the young characters are teen
characters in the show the high school
world which we are loaded with such
great fresh talent I'm rooting for them
they're gonna keep us going you know
these these two old guys China trying to
keep the show going we have these great
young kids to support it and their
stories are as compelling as Daniel and
Johnny stories and that's what's so
wonderful about the show
you